[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
what's up prof
hello walter hello martin we're going to
continue where we left off we haven't
even got to the
the spicy parts yet no and we need some
time to
really look at this important subject so
let's open with the word of prayer our
heavenly father thank you once again
for bringing us that we can continue
this discussion this most important
subject
so we ask that you enlighten us
enlighten our minds and bless this
discussion in jesus
name amen so we had come in our last
discussion
to the point where we had discussed the
doctrine of sin
sin being the transgression of the law
and then we discussed whether man is
capable
of keeping the law or not and
we looked at all of those issues but the
bible is very clear you have to be
perfect as your father in heaven is
perfect and we touched on that but now
we want to go into a little bit more
detail
sir martin we really have to look at
this
issue of moral perfection
because if you have to be perfect like
your father in heaven
is perfect and humanity is going to come
to the point when probation closes
and then there will be a time when
you will be standing without a mediator
how does this work
let's look at those those issues
so noah webster in his 1828 dictionary
has a definition of what moral
perfection
means let's read that definition
carefully
moral perfection is the complete
possession
of all moral excellence
as in the supreme being
or the possession of such
moral qualities and virtues
as a thing is capable of
that's really interesting definition
all right so there are two aspects yes
the one
is moral excellence is that
which you will find in god yeah so be ye
perfect
as god is perfect as your father in
heaven is perfect
right and then this little word or
it's also the possession of such
moral qualities and virtues
as a thing is capable of
so the best level of perfection that i
can achieve
that i'm capable of is also defined
as model perfection that's interesting
yeah
but the one could be considerably lower
than the other one right
correct now is this a definition
that is acceptable in the bible many
people will say
no you have to be at that level because
the bible says be ye perfect as your
father in heaven is perfect right
but then the bible also says if you say
you are without sin you're a liar
so no which one is it right
so let's see if we can get some help
from the spirit of prophecy
the injunction of christ is be ye
therefore perfect as your father which
is in heaven
is perfect he here shows us
that we may be as perfect in
our sphere as god
is in his sphere
martin is that in harmony with the
webster con dictionary
yeah absolutely right there are two
levels of perfection here
the one is the sphere of god and the
other one
is the sphere of man two levels
and they are not necessarily the same
but both are defined as perfect
correct okay the question is
will we ever attain to the model
excellence of christ
in other words if that is the case if
the one is here and the other one is
down here
will we ever grow to be
level so that we are as perfect as god
is perfect
some will say yes right because the
scripture
says yes but but there's a balancing
verse which says
if you say this you're you're a lie a
liar
okay so it's complicated all right let's
see this
christ practiced the most rigid
self-denial in resisting the manifold
temptations
of the adversary he conquered satan in
the long
fast of the wilderness and when he came
to him as an
angel of light offering the dominion of
the world
in exchange for his worship
he made sacrifices that will never be
required of
man as man can never
attain to his exalted character whoa
mm-hmm his whole earthly life
was a demonstration of perfect
submission to his father's will
the course of christ and that of satan
present the complete contrast
of the life of an obedient with that of
a disloyal son
so according to this statement man will
never attain to the absolute moral
excellence of god
that's a given in that statement so in
other words the two spheres
will never totally equalize
right does this
mean that they cannot get closer no
it means they can get closer they can
get close
they have to get closer they have to get
closer okay
excellent so we've established that
there are
two spheres of model excellence one is
the sphere in which god operates
one is the sphere in which humanity
operates
now then there's the issue of propensity
to sin the leaning
towards sin be careful
exceedingly careful as to how you dwell
upon the human nature of christ
do not set him before the people as a
man
with the propensities of sin
he is the second adam the first adam was
created a
pure sinless being you see here that
adam is referred to
before the fall for the fall as a
sinless being
without a taint of sin upon him he was
in the image of god he could fall
and he did fall through transgressing
did he have freedom of choice then yes
obviously then he wasn't pre-destined
right no
so that doctrine must be wrong correct
because of sin his posterity was born
with propensities of disobedience
but jesus christ was the only begotten
son of god
monogamy is unique
one of a kind right correct
he took upon himself human nature and
was tempted
in all points as human nature is tempted
he could have sinned he could have
fallen but not for one moment
was there in him an evil propensity
he was assailed with temptations in the
wilderness
as adam was assailed with temptations in
eden
so he had no propensity do
we have a propensity yes yes
does that mean that you are slaves to
that propensity no
okay we need to be careful right
by what means shall the young man
repress
his evil propensities this one
is a very interesting one it comes from
gospel workers
and develop that which is noble and good
in his character
let him heed the words whether therefore
ye
eat or drink or whatever ye do do
all to the glory of god quoting 1
corinthians 10 31
here is a principle that is to underlie
every motive thought and act
unholy passions must be crucified
they will clamor for indulgence
but god has implanted in the heart
high and holy purposes and desires
and these need not be debased
it is only when we refuse to submit to
the control of reason and conscience
that we are dragged down paul declared i
can do
all things through christ yes
so there are two things that are very
important here yeah
i must strive against my evil
propensities
god has implanted in the heart
this desire and
i do not need to be debased so the
question is
martin can i keep the law
not in yourself not in your own strength
no
but can i keep it yes otherwise he
couldn't have said go and sin no more
right
yes so does that change the fact that i
have an evil propensity
no no i have an evil propensity i have a
bent towards sin yes
i have an evil desire if i
walk past something that my eyes should
not behold
there is a natural inclination
to look
but i must fight against that evil
propensity and say
that is defiling i will
not look what that means that i must cut
out
most of what the media presents in the
world today is that correct yes
most of what's out there in the world
correct
so basically let's say i'm an alcoholic
then i must make a model decision
i will not drink and i will not
go on to satan's ground and put myself
into temptation i will not frequent the
bars
because even if i think i stand at some
stage i will
fall right so i must fight against the
evil propensity
and i can be in remission and no longer
be subject to my evil propensity
does that mean my evil propensity is
gone
no but i'm no longer drinking correct
go and sin no more yes so you're not
living out your propensity propensity
correct let's say i have an evil
propensity to be
a slave to pornography
and i meet christ yes and christ tells
me that i must cleanse this moral
defilement in me
lest something worse happens to you
and he says go and sin no more
that means anything of that nature
that i have in my possession i must
destroy
and any thing that leads me into that
direction
i must reject go and sin
no more i must keep the law of god i
must live in holiness
all right now a thought flashes into
your mind
is that sin no
it's the devil tempting you right great
and he's throwing something at you
and you're tempted yeah you're on a
website now all this
yeah stuff flashes up i mean
i work on the web pages on religious
matters
yes and i'll tell you many a time
something flashes up here and you wonder
where that come from
and there's one button that you have to
hit with rapid speed and that's called
delete
and don't allow him to defile
your mind he can tempt you yes but he
has no right
over your will yes over your choice you
still have the choice to say
no and when that voice
says but you really want to look
that's when you say lord help me
correct and then he does through you
what you are incapable of doing
yourself amen now peter
had the sin of presumption yes not me
lord
thou all forsake you not me
he got in big trouble right yep okay
he got into big big trouble and when he
had been through that trouble
the lord said to him feed my sheep
and then he said to him feed my lambs he
even entrusted the lambs to him
why because he had learned that the sin
of presumption
is a major obstacle on the in the
christian
walk correct he realized
not out of himself he will he's able
only through christ so in many of my
lectures in the past
i lay a lot of emphasis on justification
because i'm not saved by my own
works or anything inside of me
i'm saved solely by the righteousness of
christ
and some will impute that to me as
saying
that you have a license to sin or that
you cannot keep the law
i will deny that categorically i am
saying you must keep the law yes and i'm
not saying only you must i say you can
in your sphere to the model
excellence that you are capable of
you must keep the law
so your unholy passions will clamor for
indulgence
but god has implanted in the heart high
and holy purposes and desires and you
can do all things through christ
jesus and like joseph you
can run right
so he fought against his propensities
yes
that's a very good comparison
now let's get to the nitty-gritty there
is a marked distinction between
perfection and sinlessness
so martin you can become very confused
not only
in the spirit of prophecy but also
in the scriptures and believe me
you can you can be
come so confused that you do not know
where we are heading
all right let's let's try and be
very precise there are far
more quotes than we have here on the
screen
and you can put a link in about a
document
where more of the quotes are available
yes
we must strive daily against
outward evil and inward sin
if we would reach the perfection of
christian character
review an errol 1882
so there's a striving to be done it is a
warfare
where the spirit of christ the model
character before
us we must ever strive for perfection
every soul has a character to form for
everlasting life
the christian's life is a constant
warfare against the slavery of passion
we are cursed as it were
with a fallen nature correct and that
fallen nature tells me i want to one do
one thing
and the spirit and the word tell me
there is a better way and the
choice always lies with me
yes and often i will seek
excuses so that i can go the path of my
nature
yes but if i have a relationship with
christ
then i can say i have broken with that i
don't
want to be like that that's where the
presumption
is where presumption comes in this if
you have excuses
most of the time you use presumption to
say
that my excuses are legit the woman you
gave me
the serpent beguiled me no you said yes
even in that choice adam had the
presumption
along with eve that god won't be so
exact
exactly he loved them too much to be
so exact that you would punish them for
correct eating
correct and today we hear the excuse
over and over and over again it's my
upbringing
my parents treated me like this i was
abused as a child
yeah this that than the other not that
that's not bad
but it always comes back to your choice
so is this in harmony that we must
strive
daily against this thing called sin
this is what the spirit of prophecy says
luke chapter 13 verse 24
strive to enter into the straight gate
for many i say unto you will seek to
enter it and shall not be able
it is absolutely scriptural you know
what's mind-boggling to me
is that so many people will say
this person is a false prophet
but i don't think they've ever read in
in any detail
when they say these false prophets some
say she had
a brain condition yes writing these
things
well i'll tell you something these are
the most sublime brain conditions i've
ever read
none need fail of attaining in his
sphere
to perfection of christian character you
know
if you read this martin it gives you
hope
when you read that you have to be
exactly
as perfect as the highest standard in
the universe
or else you will lost you will tend to
despair
and i've seen many people that have
despaired so we have to be very careful
we must not take away the glory from god
and we must not take away the obligation
of man
and there you will bring those two
together
there you must find harmony right so
read this carefully
none need fail of attaining in his
sphere
to perfection of christian character by
the sacrifice of christ provision has
been made for the believer to receive
all things
that pertain to life and godliness
god calls upon us to reach the standard
of perfection
and places before us the example of
christ's character
in his humanity perfected by a life of
constant resistance of evil the savior
showed that
through cooperation with divinity
human beings may in this life attain to
perfection of character
let's read it again in his fear
never leave that out or else you will
despair correct and christ is ever
the example yes to strive for
yes and he fought the battle on my
behalf correct and it just
also states along with scripture it's a
constant thing
it's not a once an ending
that old man of sin must die
every day every day and if you fall on a
banana pill
what does he say we have an advocate
with the father absolutely we have an
advocate
not that you should sin no but if it
happens not willfully but because
of circumstances or whatever you
fell you have an advocate we will often
have to come to the feet of jesus
and confess our sins the sin of
presumption lies
close beside the virtue of perfect faith
and confidence in god satan flattered
himself that he could take advantage of
the humanity of christ to urge him
over the line of trust to presumption
upon this point many souls are wrecked
satan tried to deceive christ through
flattery
he admitted that he was right in the
wilderness in his faith and confidence
that god was his father
under the most trying circumstances and
then urged christ to give him one
more proof of his entire dependence upon
god
one more evidence of his faith that he
was the son of god
by casting himself from the temple
he told christ that if he was indeed the
son of god he had nothing to fear for
angels were at hand to uphold him
satan gave evidence that he understood
the scriptures by the use
he made of them martin is he going to
come to us with scripture
absolutely right yeah if you
underestimate
the adversary then you're in trouble
then you're going to be
i i'm astounded
at how many people presumptuously
command
the devil to do this or that or the
other
when not even gabriel could withstand
him
isn't that amazing just think of this
if he tempted christ
how much more when it turned out
he had no propensity and i have
propensities
so that just shows you that without
christ that did overcome him
there's no way you will be able to do it
no absolutely not
and while we cannot claim perfection of
the flesh
we may have christian perfection of the
soul
that is an astounding statement what
does that mean
i am here in
a fallen nature
and yet i can transcend it
by accepting the atonement of christ
and appropriating it to myself by faith
and opening that door so that he can
work
the good works in me by his power
so in actual fact that says
we may have christian perfection of the
soul
but not of the flesh meaning christ
perfection
not in your own correct through the
sacrifice made in our behalf
sins may be perfectly forgiven
now that is a wonderful statement so
your
sins are perfectly forgiven it doesn't
mean that you have become sinless no
you're still
sinful in your nature but you do not
have to act upon it
and in your sphere you can resist it and
overcome but god is the one
that gives the power because our
dependence is not
in what man can do it is in what
god can do for man through christ
through faith in his blood all may be
made
perfect in christ jesus thank god
we are not dealing with impossibilities
we may claim sanctification
we may enjoy the favor of god we are
not to be anxious about what christ and
god
think of us but about what god thinks of
christ
our substitute that is beautiful
how does that make you feel martin is
this balance
that's hope that's hope so
you can dissect these writings
and you can take all of the verses which
point
to duty and neglect
statements such as these and
become totally despaired and if you
bring them into harmony
then you have
up and that's where he should be that's
where you should be
i cannot do this on my own
i have to do it with christ but i have
to do it you have to do it
correct now here's the question then
can we be totally sinless
now there are many that say well that's
where you must go
right you must be totally sinless now
really i can say off the bat you can be
totally sinless
now people will say what's he saying if
christ forgives you
your sins perfectly then you are what
then you're sinless perfectly sinless
but who did the forgiving
christ christ the forgiving can i say
in my strength i can be perfectly
sinless no
no then i'm making him a liar right all
right so let's read it
in the spirit of prophecy the word
sinless
always pertains to jesus the angels
unfallen worlds heaven and the state of
adam before the fall
we just read that adam was sinless right
here's one example god could have
proclaimed his
truth through sinless angels but this is
not his plan he chooses human beings
men compassed with infirmity as
instruments in the working out of his
design
the son of god stooped to uplift the
fallen
for this he left the sinless worlds on
high
the 1909 that loved him
and came to this earth to be wounded for
our transgression and bruised for
our iniquities quoting isaiah
he the sinless one was treated as we
deserve that we
fallen and sinful might be treated as he
deserved
there by the way is a beautiful chiasm
yeah
so here we have sinlessness
it pertains to christ and the unfallen
beings
and adam and eve before the fall it does
not apply
to me no and it does not apply to you
or anyone who has ever walked the face
of the earth
other than christ
let those who feel inclined to make a
high profession of holiness
look into the mirror of god's law
as they see its far-reaching claims and
understand
its work as a discerner of the thoughts
and intents of the heart they will not
boast of sinlessness
if we says john not separating himself
from his brethren
say that we have no sin we deceive
ourselves and the truth is not in us
if we say that we have not sinned we
make him a liar and his word is not in
us if we confess our sins he is faithful
and just to forgive us our sins and to
cleanse us from all unrighteousness 1
john
chapter 1 the apostle paul declares
i know that in me that is in my flesh
dwelleth no good
thing romans 7 18. to those who have
tried so hard to obtain by faith
so-called holy flesh i would say you
cannot obtain it
not a soul of you has holy flesh now no
human being on earth has holy flesh it
is an
impossibility we're all
sinners sinners it's our condition
now how long will we be in this state
martin
so long as satan reigns we shall have
self to subdue
besetting sins to overcome so long as
life shall last
there will be no stopping place
no point which we can reach and say
i have fully attained sanctification is
the result
of lifelong obedience
never can you say i have attained no
do you know martin that i've met people
that have told me that
they've told me they've become totally
sinless
we cannot say i'm sinless until this
vile body is changed and fashioned like
unto his glorious body but if we
constantly seek to follow jesus the
blessed hope is ours of standing before
the throne of god without spot or
wrinkle
or any such thing complete in christ
robed in his righteousness
and perfection the only way i can become
perfect is in christ
when human beings receive holy flesh
they will not remain on the earth but
will be taken to heaven
while sin is forgiven in this life its
results are not only removed
selected messages so in other words
martin
i will be in this state until christ
comes
yes if you're sinless
that means you're in heaven then you're
in heaven correct
now here's a beautiful statement
the nearer we come to jesus
and the more clearly we discern the
purity of his character
the more clearly shall we see the
exceeding sinfulness of sin
and the less shall we feel like exalting
ourselves
there will be a continual reaching out
of the soul of the god a continual
earnest heartbreaking confession of sin
and humbling of the heart before
him no deep-seated love for jesus can
dwell in the heart
that does not realize its own sinfulness
the soul that is transformed by the
grace of christ will admire his divine
character
but if we do not see our own moral
deformity it is
unmistakable evidence that we have not
had a view of the beauty and excellence
of christ
those are very powerful statements
it just shows presumption
is a very dangerous thing so we need
this balance
yeah do we need to be perfect martin yes
yes
must we keep the law martin yes can we
keep the law
yes but not in our own strength
but in our sphere we can in our sphere
we can so we must exercise the will
and we must keep the law and we can keep
the law
and if the moral excellence
of the divine being is imputed to us
then we stand before god as perfect as
he is
but to claim it for myself is nothing
short of presumption
can we then therefore become sinless
we can only become sinless by a decree
but we cannot become sinless in our
own nature not until this
vile body is changed unto his glorious
body can the decree go into effect
exactly so if i can
put that in my understanding we can only
become
sinless if we've confessed our sins
and then at the end when jesus comes
and we are translated and goes to heaven
then we become
sinless yes there's a statement
in the spirit of prophecy that says we
may never utter it
but he may utter it because if he blots
out your sins
then he has declared you sinless
yes those who have felt the sanctifying
and transforming power of god must not
fall into the dangerous era of thinking
that they are sinless
that they have reached the highest state
of perfection or beyond the reach of
temptation
the standard the christian is to keep
before him is the purity
and loveliness of the character of
christ
so it's christ's character day by day
he may be putting on new beauties and
reflecting to the world more
and still more of the divine image
so never can i say i am sinless
never on this side of eternity
even after the close of probation until
this vile body has been changed into his
glorious body
i cannot utter it yes it's just a fact
some of them have even reached the
almost hopeless position
that they cannot sin that is the most
dangerous position i am now so holy
i cannot sin anymore i've i've received
holy flesh
and it is fascinating to me martin that
even amongst
prominent clergy in the world there are
many that have transgressed the law of
god
specifically in many cases the seventh
commandment
and have justified it because they are
holy therefore it is not sin
correct that is incredible that is that
that's how the devil works that's how he
works he convinces you yeah
that that you are now sinless
and then that you actually you're holy
now that you become sinless
so as a reward some
things that's against the law of god is
permissible it's permissible
correct and we find this not only in
christianity
we find it in all religions and i don't
want to go into the other religions now
and what some of their teachings are
but basically that is what some of them
very succinctly saying
so how careful must we be
how careful must we be of the sin of
presumption
we must be so distrustful
of self the spirit of prophecy also says
that presumption is the counterfeit
for faith correct and they're like so
close together and we can see it in the
in
the manifestations that we see in the
world it's unbelievable
so of course those that say that they
cannot sin
these of course have no further use of
the lord's prayer which teaches us to
pray
that our sins may be forgiven and but
very little use for the bible as they
profess to be led by the spirit
and are there not many religions in the
world today that say that the spirit is
normative
didn't we look at many videos in our
past
series where they said if you have the
same manifestation
in your group as i have in my group then
the spirit says that we are one
yes so protestantism and catholicism if
they have the same manifestations let's
say
of gifts of the spirit
then they are one even though their
doctrines differ
you see that links to me where we
started off with you have to
be one in mind one accord one accord
they say if they are led by the spirit
and the bible then the and don't use the
bible to
determine whether that spirit says the
same thing yes
that that's fine because that's where
the ecumenical movement comes in
that's how it works you may not preach
doctrine in the economical movement so
you've got the spirit
but you leave the word out that's
exactly what it is
what a terrible deception they think
they are completing christ and know not
that they are wretched blind miserable
poor and naked
now this is
a very tricky subject
because if christ is going to leave the
heavenly sanctuary
and his mediation stops
when the decree goes out
that the close of probation has come
then
basically you are standing here on this
earth
without a mediator and therefore there
are
these notions that you will have to
stand
basically without
sin in a perfect condition in that
period
of time so you must reach the state of
moral
perfection that is required for this and
this is something that will be granted
to the final generation
that's that's what's being said yes
that's what
some believe now again i would like to
say
if all do not see it exactly that way
that should not make us enemies
because we can see that this is a very
complicated topic and there are many
ways of looking at it
so let's show some tolerance for each
other
and not put us into categories of
damnation because we do not see it
exactly like the next person right
but let us look at this issue of
standing without a mediator
because there are some things that we
need to address here
those who are living upon the earth when
the intercession of christ
shall cease in the sanctuary above or to
stand
in the sight of a holy god without a
mediator
before we go on can you please just
explain to us
what this means standing without a
mediator
because i don't think everybody
in understands because the adventists
have
the spirit of prophecy and is telling us
that
there will be a time when christ will
not be mediating
and this might be something strange to
some of the viewers
okay let's look at the logic behind it
we know that probation will close
now generally the view in the world out
there is that the christian church will
be
raptured before the time of the plagues
and the great tribulation
but typology tells us that that is not
the case
because the children of israel were
there when the plagues fell
but god made a difference and
the last seven of the ten plagues never
affected the israelites only
affected the egyptians right yes so in
typology
we know that god's people will be
here before the final deliverance
and during the period of the plagues
falling
now the plagues only fall after the
close of
probation okay so god
closes the probation in other words his
mediatorial role as intercessor for the
sinner
ceases and in that period
of the great time of trouble while the
plagues are falling
those that have been redeemed by christ
and in christ stand without
him as mediator because his mediation
has
ceased so this is what it means and so
there will be a time
when god's people will be without a
mediator
so when the revelation says and we've
dealt with that michael stands up that's
when probation closes
correct and then there's a period that
the last
plagues will be falling on earth correct
and in that period the
church will not be raptured away it will
be going through this period correct
and that's the time with this mediation
and now the question then arises martin
you're standing without a mediator and
you have a sinful nature
what if you fall in that period it could
be a few months right
so there's no mediation for that sin
then you're lost
so the argument is therefore you must
already be perfect so that you cannot
fall
now let me just take
a step back and address this with the
question
when adam and eve were perfect
and sinless could they fall
yes they could fall yes all right
is god going to by decree
create the circumstances so that you
cannot fall anymore
no no because then he would have to take
away your free will right correct
the same with the angels and then you
could ask the question
but excuse me why didn't he save us all
this trouble
and right from the beginning have
created us
without the capacity to fall
then we wouldn't have had this mess
right correct but you would have been a
robot
yes you would not have been capable
of doing anything out of the compulsion
of love
because you would have been programmed
right if you turn the wheel you're going
to go left and there's nothing you can
do about it you're going to go left
so yes there will be a time without a
mediator
and the question is what will your
situation be now we have to look at this
carefully because this is a very serious
issue
because some feel that if you do not
reach the stage of absolute perfection
in this last generation then you have to
go through this period when you have
this fallen nature
then what if you fall
then satan will have been right by
saying you can't keep the law of god
and therefore you have to reach this
stage
and only the last generation is going to
succeed in this
this is what some people believe right
but let's just look at it carefully
so i ask for some patience and some
tolerance so that we can just discuss
this issue
their robes must be spotless their
character must be purified from sin
by the blood of sprinkling that's an
important statement
so their sins have been completely
forgiven by christ right
yes nothing that defiles will go to
heaven so there's nothing wrong with the
statement the statement is
absolutely spot on because the bible
says nothing that defiles will enter
into heaven
so all of the redeemed must be spotless
by the blood of sprinkling yes
through the grace of god and their own
diligent effort his fear
our sphere they must be conquerors in
the battle with evil
while the investigative judgment is
going forward in heaven
while the sins of penitent believers are
being removed from the sanctuary
there is to be a special work of
purification of putting away of sin
amongst god's people upon earth
this work is more clearly presented in
the message of revelation 14.
so this is absolutely true we'll stand
without a mediator
you will have to be perfect you will
have to be undefiled
you will have to be declared without
defilement
therefore how do you do this
okay martin here's something called the
ceiling
because the bible talks about the seal
of god
let's just read that those that overcome
the world
the flesh and the devil
will be the favored ones who shall
receive the seal of the living god
only those who in their attitude before
god
are filling the position of those who
are repenting
and confessing their sins in the great
antitypical atonement will be recognized
and marked as worthy of god's
protection
so in this time when you are sealed
you will stand under god's protection
that's an important point just as soon
as the people of god are
sealed in their foreheads it is not any
seal or mark that can be seen
but a settling into the truth both
intellectually
and spiritually so they cannot be moved
so in other words the seal of god is
when you have
so settled in the truth
that you cannot be moved so what is
truth jesus is the way the truth and the
life
thy word is truth and thy law is truth
those are the three definitions in the
bible
you must be absolutely settled on that
you must know
what sin is you must trust in the merits
of christ
and you must have internalized his
character by
studying it in the word
just as soon as god's people are sealed
and prepared for the shaking
it will come indeed it has begun already
the judgments of god are now upon the
land and we may
know what is coming
so the shaking has already commenced
yes and it gets worse and worse and
worse
as we go along so martin let's address
this with a few questions
this question of standing without a
mediator
and now we have to be very
careful as to how we approach it
the first question i would like to ask
and i'm going to use you as a guinea pig
okay does standing without the mediator
mean that we are standing without the
righteousness of christ
definitely not definitely not no so
you're standing with the righteousness
of christ
okay how perfect is that righteousness
absolute absolutely perfect right
then i would like to ask another
question how perfect is the following
decree
and this is the decree that goes out at
the close of probation
when michael stands up revelation 22
11 he that is unjust
let him be unjust still and he which is
filthy
let him be filthy still and he that is
righteous let him be righteous still
and he that is holy let him be holy
still who says this
god god says this so this is the decree
that christ himself issues right
michael's standing up
so christ is pronouncing this okay
now when he says let him
that is righteous be righteous still
and let him that is holy let him be holy
still by the way
how did these people over here that are
standing now without a mediator
receive perfect righteousness through
christ
through christ yes okay so they're
standing in the righteousness of christ
which is perfect
now there's a decree you will
remain righteous
how perfect is that decree perfect
because it's christ
that's given you all right so those that
stand there
in the righteousness of christ will they
remain righteous
yes him that is righteous but there's no
mediator
but there's a decree yes you will remain
righteous
and he that is holy let him be holy
still
and why does he say that because he has
sealed them
and what does that seal mean settled
into the truth so that you cannot be
moved now will the unrighteous be
shouting at you
in the time of the plagues will they
be wanting to kill you in the time of
the plagues right
definitely definitely will everything in
the book be thrown at you in the time of
the plagues
it will be a time such as never was
will the army of pharaoh and he
typically come after you to try and wipe
you off the face
of the earth yep definitely okay so
we're going through a very similar
experience
as did the children of israel
and are you going to be moved
not if you've been sealed
not if you're so settled in the truth
that you cannot be moved
and by decree yes you will remain
righteous though
because from this time onward that this
decree has been issued
the righteous will remain righteous
that's what it says
and the unrighteous will remain
unrighteous
so there's no reprieve from them they
cannot change
from unrighteousness to righteousness
because there's no mediator
but the others won't change because
they're so settled in the truth they
cannot be moved yes and the others are
so settled in the untruth
that they won't be moved all right now
let's get to the nitty-gritty
here's my next question how perfect
are all that have ever lived that will
be raised
up at the last trump and will
the last generation be any more perfect
than they
no they won't be any more perfect and
how perfect
will they be that have died how perfect
will they be
must be complete perfect because they've
been covered by the righteousness of
christ
okay so here's my question
do you have any advantage if you happen
to be alive
in the end over those that have died
before
no how perfect are they just as perfect
as you will be when you get translated
so is there any advantage
that the last generation has over any of
those that died before
they cannot have no because
jesus christ the same yesterday today
and forever
okay all right there's another question
for you martin while we're at the
questions
has the plan of salvation ever changed
no how were adam and eve saved
the same way as we are saved today all
right if nothing that defiles
enters into heaven
and only the last generation
is capable of doing this then how did
enoch go to heaven
if nothing that defiles goes into heaven
i want to ask you the question how did
enoch go to heaven
the only way is by christ declaring him
righteous
so the only way the last generation can
go to heaven
even without a mediator is because
christ has coveted them with his
righteousness and said you will remain
righteous still
does that mean that he has now decreed
that you cannot fall no
and why not because he came to die for
your free will
so why would he give up your free will
at the last moment
then he died for nothing right he could
have created you in the first place
it's the same argument that the law is
not
as taken away so really martin when you
when you discuss this issue and you go
through these questions in my
in my understanding and if somebody
wants to differ that's
fair enough i'm not arguing with them
there will be no difference
between this generation and any other
previous generation the only way to get
to heaven
is by having the passport that takes you
which is the righteousness of christ
imparted and
imputed imputed being justification
imparted being sanctification and yes i
have to exercise my will
within my sphere but here is a decree
and we read earlier that he will give
his angels
charge over you yeah they will
shield you yes yeah they will surround
you
they will keep those evil angels away
from you
those evil angels will incite the wicked
to go and kill you but it is hopeless
for them
to try and convince you why
because you're settled into you're so
settled in the truth that you cannot be
moved
so if you want to be part of the last
generation
that is actually going to here stand
without the mediator
how settled in the truth must you be
absolutely
so what must you have done you have to
get christ and you must study right yes
so those 10 virgins they all had oil
that means they all studied the word
correct
and when the cry went out the bridegroom
cometh
they trimmed their lamps in other words
they let their lamps shine but some of
them didn't have enough oil enough
yeah and they ran back and they tried to
get more oil
so they obviously went and searched the
scriptures i believe
that some people with all the crises
that are happening in the world today
and with all these pandemics and all of
these rules that are coming in
green passes and all of these issues
that some are saying oh is the
bridegroom coming
and the question is how much time do we
have to get oil
we need to we need to get our act
together right yes
now this pertains
to the people of god that give the lord
cry
and thousands and thousands and
thousands
by the grace of god will come
out of babylon
are they on the same level in terms of
the studies as
all the others that have studied this
for years no
but they see what they need to see for
the time in which they are living
they make their choice that god
is the ruler of this universe
that he has a law that he ha they have
to obey the law
they take their stand with the people of
god
and they are declared what righteous
now my question to you again martin
if they are declared righteous and
they've just come out of babylon
don't they also go through the time of
trouble without a mediator
correct so
iman if that is the case
then is there any difference between
their standing
and their righteousness and their
capacity to fall
and those that have been
educated in the loud cry
no there's no difference right you've
got a type
a thief on the cross excellent
now the thief on the cross
here's the question was he justified
yes absolutely right remember me when
you come into my kingdom
verily verily i say unto you today you
will be with me in the kingdom of heaven
was he justified yes
all right without sanctification no one
will see god
did he have much time for sanctification
but did he have sanctification yes
how do you know christ declared him
righteous
all right but that's not sanctification
that's justification
that's good i'm glad you i'm glad you're
thinking about that one all right let's
let's compare the two
there were two thieves right and the one
was
mocking christ and the other one said
hey
we are criminals we deserve what we're
getting
but this man did nothing wrong he is
righteous
this one was swearing and cursing and
carrying on
this one was having a conversation with
christ
and christ died before him
did he then start cursing and carrying
on or do you think he
rested in this knowledge and kept his
mouth shut
and thank god for the grace that he had
received yes
sanctification he showed the fruits of
sanctification he stopped swearing
for that short period of time he had it
all
yeah did he have baptism
no no but he had the baptism of the holy
spirit
exactly so these are all very
interesting points
so martin i believe
that salvation has had the same criteria
for all time and for me to say
that i have to reach a level that is
higher than that of moses
because he had to die and didn't go
through the time of trouble
in terms of being able to stand with a
righteous character
when he talked to god face to face
yeah and when they doubted his position
his brother and his sister
god said to them were you not afraid to
speak against my servant moses
and when that shekinah glory departed
there was miriam and she was leprous
yeah and moses said healer lord please
please healer and god said no
put her out of the camp for seven days
let's see let her think about herself
and then she can come back so he healed
her
but he he permitted the consequences
right
so are we going to say
that we are in a better position or we
have to reach a better position than
moses reached
well then you have to be consistent and
say
well we have to reach a better position
than inuh reached
and let's say the righteous that have
died as
martyrs get up out of the grave with
that
glorious glorified body
are they any worse off have i reached a
higher state than them
i think that is verging on
presumption but if people see it
differently
let's not make a war about it
we cannot say i am sinless until this
vile body is changed and fashioned like
unto his glorious body
that'll happen when he comes again right
we've seen this quote before
but i can't say
i don't want to sit and i'm not going to
sin
i want to stay on the narrow
path and the decree and the sealing
and the protection of the angels will
guard me in the time when i
am without an intercessor if we
constantly seek to follow jesus the
blessed hope is ours of standing before
the throne of god without spot or
wrinkle
or any such thing complete
in christ robed in his righteousness and
perfection
and here's another thought martin this
is going to happen throughout all
eternity
our life work here is a preparation for
the life eternal
the education begun here will not be
completed in this life
it will be going forward through all
eternity
ever progressing never completed
more and more fully will be revealed the
wisdom and the love of god in the plan
of redemption
my question to you is
will we continue to grow in
character perfection throughout eternity
yes
will we ever reach the level of god
no we will go closer and again but it
will
always be he'll always be
the source of our admin
yes and this is the beautiful
plan of redemption and then in that
final analysis in the banishment of
satan from heaven
god declared his justice why because he
had
transgressed the law and the wages
of transgressing the law was
death and maintained the honor of his
throne
but when man had sinned through the
yielding to the deceptions of this
apostate spirit
god gave an evidence of his love by
yielding up his only begotten son to die
for the fallen race
in the atonement the character of god
stands revealed
the mighty argument of the cross
demonstrates to the whole universe that
god was in no wise responsible for the
course of sin
that lucifer had chosen there goes
predestination
right yes that it was no
arbitrary withdrawal of divine grace
no deficiency in the divine government
which inspired
in him the spirit of rebellion
and as we read in 1 john 4 16 and we if
we have
known and believed the love that god has
to us
god is love and that he that dwelleth in
love dwelleth in god
and god in him this is unselfish agapeo
love
that's the kind of love that we need to
acquire
that's the kind of love that peter said
he didn't have
right because the lord asked him
do you agape of me and he said no lord
i just i'm not capable of that
i only file you but later
in peter's ladder he said
and the last one is agapeo
we have to attain to it
but it will not be that way when the
great controversy will come to an end
then with the plan of redemption having
been completed the character of god
stands clearly revealed to all created
intelligences
the principles of his law are seen to be
perfect and unchangeable sin has
revealed its nature
satan his character the extermination of
sin
will prove god's love and establish his
honor before the universe
so martin the doctrine of the law
and of sin is part and parcel
of this redemptive process you cannot
remove it
and that is why this study
is of utmost importance because
we must learn at the basis
of god's government is the law then we
need to be in harmony with the law
in our sphere yes let's pray
heavenly father this doctrine
has caused so much suffering
and pain and death in the world
millions have been executed
because they do not see it exactly as
the next person sees it
and lord we pray that the promise
that you will lead us into all truth
will be
fulfilled in us and i pray that
the people in the world will see
that the character of god is linked to
his law
and that they will understand that the
death on the cross
demonstrated the justice of god
and lifted up the veracity of the law
and that the mercy demonstrated on the
cross
gave fallen beings such as us
access to the throne of god what a
miracle
thank you thank you lord jesus
amen amen
thank you for watching this video to
subscribe to our channel
click here to get notifications click on
the bell
to watch the next video click here
thank you and we'll see you again